قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي اف جلنت ان
اسرائيل تفضل الحل السياسيه على العسكري
فيما يخص التعامل مع التهديد الصادر عن
حزب الله مؤكدا ان الوقت بات ينفد واشار
جالنت اشاد بسير المواجهات العسكريه ونجاح
الجيش الاسرائيلي حسب قوله في دفع عناصر
حزب الله للتراجع من المنطقه الحدوديه
جراء تكثيف الهجمات الاسرائيليه بمناطق
متفرقه من جنوب
لبنان
هناك بديلان لهذا الوضع البديل السياسي
ونحن نعمل عليه بكل ما اوتينا من قوه
التقيت المبعوث الخاص للرئيس الامريكي
عاموس هوك شين وقريبا سالتقي وزير
الخارجيه انتوني بلينكن لمناقشه احتمال
التوصل الى تفاهم يؤدي الى اتفاق يمكن
سكان الشمال من العوده بامان الى
منازلهم بحثت هنا في مقر القياده العامه
الشماليه البديل الثاني وهو احتمال القيام
بعمليه عسكريه في الجبهه الشماليه من اجل
السماح بعوده سكان الشمال الى منازلهم
اننا نفضل طريق التسويه السياسيه والاتفاق
لكننا قريبون من النقطه التي ستنقلب فيها
الساعه
الرمليه